i'm agent mobius by the way  are you taking me somewhere to kill me  no that's where you just were  i'm taking you someplace to talk but i  don't like to talk  but you do like to lie which you just  did because we both know  you love to talk not keep talking  how long have you been here i don't know  it's hard to say you know time passes  differently here in the tva  what does that mean you'll catch up  so you're part of the tva's courageous  and dedicated workforce  yes you were created by the timekeepers  to protect the sacred timeline correct  is that funny the idea that your little  club decides the fate of trillions of  people across all of existence at the  behest of three  space lizards yes it's funny it's absurd  i thought you didn't like to talk  you